vas-y mon lot alors c'est melania trump
a way elle débarque dans le bunker de la
maison blanche
et là il ya donald trump qui avec tout
le staff toute l'armée américaine a dit
mais donald tu fais quoi dit je fais
quoi
je fais quoi je me prépare la troisième
guerre mondiale et si ça marche comme je
le veux bientôt on va tuer 100 millions
de musulmans et sans dentiste bananière
a fait sans dentiste pourquoi son
dentiste
et là il regarde l'état major dévoyer
les mecs les arabes ça va passer comme
une lettre à la poste
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
as bâti alors c'est un arabe qui vaut
sanaa qui va au pôle emploi se fait six
ans qu'il en france et donc il va il a
rendez-vous avec sa conseillère au pôle
emploi et il lui dit écoutez ça et j'en
ai marre de toucher les aides d'un truc
et où la société le rsa le chômage en
est marre de tout ça je veux travailler
à lui de me calmer vous monsieur en plus
ça tombe bien vous ai de la chance
aujourd'hui on a un milliardaire qui
nous a appelés il cherche un chauffeur
et un homme à tout faire pour sa fille
nymphomane il faut il faut vraiment que
à chaque fois qu'elle veut y aller vous
y allez vraiment vous avez une maserati
une ferrari une porsche à disposition
vous êtes payé cent mille euros par an
et vous travaillez que quatre jours dans
l'aspect comme ceux du blé non c'est pas
possible ici mais c'est vrai mais vous
foutez de ma gueule
il aimait lequel de nous deux a commencé
avant
[Applaudissements]
dis moi j'ai une histoire juive
vas-y c'est une grand mère qui est
tranquille qui à deauville et elle
tricote sur la plage elle regarde ses
petits enfants qui jouent au bord de
l'eau elle tricote elle regarde elle
tricote et là il ya une lame de fond qui
arrive qui prend son petit fils et qu'il
emmène au large
la grand mère elle regarde très
calmement le siège nous a fait mon dieu
c'est pas normal je fais yom kippour
depuis 75 ans j'ai élevé tous mes
enfants mes petits enfants dans ta
religion grâce à thouars j'ai tout fait
shabbat à la maison chez moi on est
chômeur shabbat on mange casher et à moi
tu me prends mon petit fils et à ce
moment-là lame de fond ramène le gosse
qui se remet à jouer sur la plage elle
regarde elle se remet genou elle fait
mon dieu je voudrais pas abuser mais il
avait une casquette 9
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
thomas julie d'amour bat julie c'est que
j'étais très amoureux de toi pendant des
années ah oui il m'a dit je suis passé
je suis passé à côté de beaucoup de ses
vrais a toujours été magnifique
je te dis et de est ce que toi tu veux
tourner une petite way à une blonde mois
basile ebah c'est un petit blond avait
acheté un portable
et puis on rentre dans un magasin de
téléphonie et puis elle dit oui bonjour
je voudrais m'acheter un portable et pas
peur enfin je voudrais savoir il dit ok
mais attendez l'opérateur on est plutôt
sur sfr orange sfr
abbas est pas fermée avaient bien
apprendre
[Applaudissements]
merci parce qu'il fait la prestation en
plus mais attends moi je voulais passer
justement juste ce sens et on a fait les
arabes on a fait les juifs
moi je voulais en faire une belge pour
rendre hommage au public belge qui nous
regardent bien sûr et à mon ami renaud
avec lequel nous visons à spectacle
s'appelle cul et chemise
pincez moi qui fais le cul et génie
laisse tomber moi je suis en plein
dedans tu vois pas hésité par se régale
avec deinove est annihilée exceptionnel
vous allez le découvrir ce soir pour ce
film le connaissent pas c'est une
immense star super c'est juste un couple
de belges d'avancé sur la plage
regardent les mouettes passer une web
qui chie sur la gueule du belge et sa
femme à le cours à la bagnole chacha un
rouleau de papier qu elle lui ramène son
mari et dia c'est trop tard elle est
partie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une une maman juive qui vit avec
son fils et elle se rend compte un
moment donné que le petit commence à
avoir des vues sur une autre femme et
elle fait tu vas partir si vous
abandonnez moment c'est ça non maman or
hier je vais t'expliquer je suis je suis
amoureuse je suis fiancée mais je vais
te faire une surprise dimanche
ma fiancée va arriver et elle va être
très deux copines à elle avec la même
robe
et comme tu m'as moment et que tu
m'aimes tu vas trouver laquelle ces met
d'accord on fait comme ça le dimanche
arrive il prépare le dîner
à midi pile trois filles avec la même
robe rouge sonne et le gain évidemment
on fait semblant qu'il les connaît bien
toutes les trois il ne fait rien du tout
et à un moment donné il s'en va la
cuisine après une demi heure et demie
alors maman tu as trouvé laquelle c est
la mairie fait c'est celle là et que sa
petite boule dorée rouge un oui mais
comment tu sais que celle je ne l'aiment
pas
il ya un mois jan 10 armes pour retrouve
sur airs et chansons et lui aussi alors
lui c'est un puits de black c'est un
truc tabac écoute en tout cas ont
attaqué par une petite en plus je suis
vraiment ravi de faire avec les patrons
de des blagues
ces deux vieux qui discutent ils ont ils
sont complètement perdus sont très potes
mais ils ont alzheimer à moins de filles
sont là et puis discutent sur un banc et
puis discute ou les deux et qui dit à
l'autre
[ __ ] je ne me rappelle de rien j'ai
aucun souvenir renier fois là c'est
l'enfer de vieillir au dessus du but
c'est con tu vois moi j'ai trouvé un
truc c j'ai trouvé le médicament qui
fait que c'est terminé je me souviens de
tout date jour or tous là où on va au
resto n'est dupe ça c'est vrai alors dit
moi je sais pas le nom du médicament
orgueil irréfléchie dit madiba le
médicament c'est ces [ __ ] c'est gelé
la battant lafleur lac etc etc et rouge
like qui a des épines d'une rose rose
c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
bon ben ali alors au mali merci d'être
là avec plaisir c'est le côté des beaux
gosses là-bas à lhassa une petite équipe
c'est la régie pas que vous êtes mort
mais bon genre c'est les mecs depuis
tout à l'heure ne put le mal est fait de
ce côté
non non non non mais arrêtez giroud look
et philippe lellouche bicycle il y avait
comme eric bloch qui émeut doit ses
cymbales
c'est un mec qui se fait arrêter pour
excès de vitesse par un flic le flic
l'arrivée du monde donnez moi votre
permis mais qui cinq ans que je me suis
fait sauter mon permis je n'ai pas de
terme
ok bon bah donnez moi la carte grise du
véhicule je l'est pas parce que la
voiture je les voulais que lucky dube a
écouté ça devient compliqué votre
histoire vous avez rien de dangereux sur
vous ici j'ai un pistolet dans un boîte
à gants bon c'est pas très grave mais
qui sort son flingue bon sortie de la
voiture et non parce que si je sors de
la voiture après je vais devoir envers
le corps dans le coffre
quel cadavre de ma soeur avec nous une
colère vous n'allez pas à liker donc les
mecs le fic rendre au tournoi sa voiture
ils appellent du renfort les renforts
arrivent via capitaine de police qui
viendront on reprend tout depuis le
début
votre permis magri sort son père mais
voilà ont permis vous avez une carte
grise
j'ai la carte grise de la voiture aurait
pas de problème je comprends pas une
histoire de pistolet dans la boîte à
gants du lent et à rien mais vous la
boîte à gants ya pas de pistolet médias
l'officier qui me dit qu'il ya le
cadavre de votre soeur dans le coffre
et puis je parie qu'il a dit que j'étais
en excès de vitesse gros menteur
[Applaudissements]
je limiterai des gars qui n'est pas que
je faisais tout c'est quand je t'en fais
non entre les deux bases il alors caméra
c1
c'est un petit journaliste du 13 heures
de jean pierre pernaut qui veut faire un
petit reportage vous savez il valait
encore c'est un petit peu là dans un
dans un village un peu perdu et là
encore c'est il va interroger le vieux
maire du village monsieur rossi qui à 90
ans donc il arrive avec son équipe
ces voix-là jeu jean pierre pernaut 13h
30 % d'audimat donc je sais bien par
d'autres villages allez-y je vais vous
poser quelques questions posent problème
alors monsieur rossi en tant que maire
de votre corps quel est votre meilleur
souvenir
j'avais une biquette
et alors un jour on a perdu l'habitude
est d'accord et alors je cherchais
partout à chercher dans les petites rues
chercher un fonds de terre le chercher
dans l'épais on ne trouvait pas la
biquette
oh oui alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
le jour est ouvert à beckett
elle était perdue dans le basque est
alors qu'est ce que nous avons la fin en
fait on a fait la fête à la petite
fontaine aurait pu dû la bulle ogier
tout le monde était péter alors qu'ici
c'est passé alors on appelait aussi il
pouvait pas dire ça c'est 13h06 jean
pierre pernaut s'est aménagé on peut pas
excuser moi rohff et la question autour
les gars c'est parti monsieur rossi
entre de votre petit village en corse
elle un peu longuet quel est votre
meilleur souvenir dit la même chose quoi
bon me souvenir j'avais un boeuf
[Musique]
on a perdu le boeuf a est alors chercher
le bo fait pas tout mais alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé on a retrouvé le boeuf
ils étaient perdus dans le basket et
alors
pas possible je suis certain je vais
changer la question voilà c'est moi le
problème monsieur aussi en tant que
maire de votre petit village en corse
quel est votre plus mauvais souvenir de
mauvais souvenirs c'est quand je me suis
perdu dans le temps pour l'apéro elle
pas bien vrai mâle janda oui alors c'est
dans une usine c'est la pause déjeuner
deux ouvriers discute et lundi à l'autre
tu connais victor hugo
non bah tu as tort tu devrais suivre les
cours du soir ou le lendemain pareil lui
dit tu connais albert einstein non bah
tu as tort tu devrais suivre les cours
du soir et surlendemain il est dit tu
connais karl marx ou tout durant n'ont
pas tort tu devrais suivre les cours des
soirées le quatrième jour et nuit vent
qu'on peut parler de quelqu'un dit tu
connais jean marie bigard non
eh ben tu as tort parce que pendant que
tu suis les cours du soir il est femme
[Applaudissements]